do me a favor bring your hands behind  there let's see what happens with that  behind the ribbons if you can yeah  that's beautiful  now do me a favor darling turn your body  that way that's it what's up there  perfect bring this the other yeah that's  beautiful what's in your face this way  that's it don't move yeah ah yeah that's  that's the one I reckon that's the one  actually I've been waiting for the opera  singer to sing and they just say lean  towards me good  tilt order go back again [ __ ] up right  you're dumber you bite your body's  perfect tilt your face [ __ ] up face more  this way well don't move that beautiful  gorgeous darling hold it hold it  Tara do the exact same pose so this need  like this  bring your hands back a bit  say  all right hold it le hui' every dumb